Superman, Superman, does whatever Kryptonians
can. Spins a web, it is nice. Makes his list,
checks it twice. Look out, here comes the
Superman. Look out, here comes the Superman.
Dude, Superman does not spin webs. If you're
going to steal the Spider-man song, at least
don't steal some of the lyrics by accident
too. I mean, what does that song have to do
with the movie, after all? It's not even about
Man of Steel.
I didn't say it was about the movie? I just
wrote a song about Superman. Five For Fighting
did it.
Well, Five For Fighting is a hugely successful
rock band and you are not. And also they're
hockey fans, which makes them cool.
I'm a hockey fan!
Dude. You're a Predators fan. That's not hockey.
You know, I know about half a million rednecks
that are gonna want to kick your ass for that
comment.
Right, right after they get done kicking your
ass for calling them rednecks.
You know who probably has a red neck? Superman.
What?!
Think about it. He spends all his time outdoors.
And he's flying, so he's even closer to the
sun than we are. I bet his neck gets sunburned
like a motherf*cker.
Dude, I mean, he's Superman. Bullets bounce
off his chest, I don't think the UV rays are
going to hurt him. Come on.
Well, someone obviously haven't seen Man Of
Steel.
I saw it with you!
I thought that was the other you.
He was there too.
Well anyway, I thought it was great.
I'm not surprised to—what? What did you
say?
Yeah, it was awesome. Dude, Superman action
has never been so freaking exhilarating.
I...
Amy Adams is the perfect Lois Lane. She's
the best Lois Lane ever, apologies to Margot
Kidder, God rest her soul.
She's still alive!
God can still rest her soul even if she's
still alive. Lord knows that woman has earned
a f*cking rest.
I'm not really prepared for you to like a
movie this much. You don't like any movies.
Well, now that's not true.
Yes it is.
I like lots of movies.
Dude, what's not to like? Alright, I mean
Christopher Nolan was obviously a steady influence
on Zach Snyder. Russell Crowe was f*cking
born to play Jor-El, I mean, damn. And if
that's not enough, I have three words for
you: Kneel Before Zod. Michael Shannon f*cking
owns in this movie.
I share a lot of these opinions and I am definitely,
definitely not okay with that. That is really
troubling me.
Well, if you really need to talk to somebody
about the movie who disagrees with you, why
don't you talk to the other you. He hates
everything.
No. He loves everything. He's like the opposite
of you. We're talking about a guy that gave
a standing ovation during the credits of Good
Day To Die Hard.
What a piece of sh*t.
Yeah, that movie's just terrible.
No, I'm talking about the guy. What a piece
of sh*t he is for liking that movie.
I'm pretty sure if you polled the audience
they would say that you're a bigger piece
of shit than he is. I'm positive of that,
actually.
Whatever. Do you want to sing my Superman
song with me or not?
No. No I do not. I don't.
Dude, I mean, you have to. You owe me a song.
You lost a bet, remember?
No, I don't remember because you roofied me
and then when I woke up you said that I lost
a bet and had to sing a song with you.
That is what happened! I even have it on tape.
Here comes the superman.
Dude, what is he even doing here? Isn't this
like, a you a me thing?
You lost a bet.
How many bets did I lose while I was uncon--
Dude, don't make me hurt you. I will kill
you.
Don't threaten me. I mean, I do have the powers
of Superman.
You don't have the powers of superman. If
anyone has the powers of superman, it's me.
Right. I have them. I can prove it. I'll prove
it.
Okay.